so in China look at Jeff's filmography
and distill it down into what he does so
well I feel like he takes these huge
concepts but tells them in a small way
yeah what would you say that makes his
work so special he's an incredibly
observant person and he trusts in this
case the truth you know what I love
about this is a true story but how often
do people tell a true story truthfully
yeah
and Jeff looks for the details and I
think he sees the better way to tell a
love story is not to write false
speeches about love but to just watch
two people in the dance of domesticity
together finding that that that
oppressive obstacle I think people like
that fall in love with this couple
because they're so extraordinary so
beguiling and beautiful individually and
and together and I think that's what
resonates from our film is that this
couple were so not that they were just
only in love but they were so decent
human beings not doesn't even do them
justice and you know they changed the
course of American legal history without
changing the nature of who they were
which was essentially good people who
wanted to have a simple life the reason
why Mildred and Richard were
extraordinary people even though they
were everyday ordinary people was
because of the love and so if you don't
focus on the people and you miss the
point of the story
you missed the reason why we got to
where we are in society
you missed the reason why it was able to
make it to the Supreme Court
it feels very timely as well because you
could equate this to not only racism
sexism but also marriage equality which
was still dealing with absolutely yeah
you know I think qualities it's not a
thing we ever just achieve as a society
it's something we're just constantly
redefining for ourselves and and right
now we're asking ourselves in this
generation how do we want to define
equality what does it mean for us right
now and I think Richard and Mildred they
show us how to have that conversation
they show us the people at the center
of these big debates and and that's what
we need to focus on is there anything
you'd like me to say to the Supreme
Court justices of the United States yeah
you tell a judge I love my wife
you